[Applause]
I'm so honored and thrilled that you
came here are you kidding me this is
gonna be a blast I'm so excited
I'm so nervous all week I still get
really nervous do you I do do you get
nervous ever
yeah yeah sometimes I get nervous how do
you deal with that
um I you know recently for example I
went to this concert recently Zach
Williams is uh this a friend of mine
who's a singer he had a show he's a
great guy if you check out Zach Williams
he brought out this uh piano player
keyboard player who uh is vision
impaired right so he walked out and he
and he was smiling and he stood there or
he sat there and he played the piano and
he's sang He's just beautiful and I was
noticing how
like his body the way he held his body
right kind of like almost like a big
speaker he was resonating this music out
of his body and he was not there was no
vanity in it because he wasn't concerned
about the way he might be looking maybe
or maybe it didn't feel that way to me
and so he was just sitting there and he
was smiling and he was so happy and I
just thought like when I go on Drew
Barrymore I'm gonna really like
think about my posture I'm gonna think
like that because I it like he gave out
this positive energy and as he was
thinking it was his voice it gave you
like room for his voice to exit his body
so I maybe I'm a little nervous now but
I just think about things like that
preparation and separation's in the
preparation right oh so I wanted to be
prepared
there you go point is go see Zach
Williams and sit up uh when people are
talking to you separation is in the
preparation yeah it's the truth that
will change my life
that's really the truth
I used to hear I used to hear the
quarterback Russell Wilson in Seattle
former Seattle Seahawk Denver Bronco
Russell Wilson a guy I really look up to
he I used to say that all the time and
it's true especially like in you know in
acting how many times
have you been in a situation where
you're like oh man I wish I'd have just
spent a little more time preparing for
this or like you leave that day after
your work and you go man I should have
tried something I should have tried it's
like if you prepare and prepare and
prepare sometimes that separates uh you
from maybe you know you the best you're
the best version of yourself from the
the version you brought the day that you
didn't prepare I don't know I I couldn't
agree more I call it showing up naked
for a test yeah like don't do it don't
do that that's do not do it that's the
truly nightmares that you have it's like
you're naked yeah because I feel naked
metaphorically yes you know yeah like
it's the reverse Emperor has no clothes
I have no clothes on a naked and
vulnerable and you know but I was like
I'll ask Chris because I got I get so
excited I want to do well and I get
excited and it's different than our
other job right like it is different I
feel like I'm on Wheels still is that
right well you're doing great really yes
you really are you really are I think
you can do this as long as you want and
you're doing great
I see your Clips all over they float all
over online there's like amazing Clips
with you all over the place and you're
really doing great that means so much
coming from you because I respect you so
much as well as like enjoy and admire
all the work you put out but you work
hard you have range which I always
thought growing up like especially in
our job that like range was the most uh
the biggest goal you know don't you I
don't want to be pinned down yeah yeah
um and I I like drama I like funny I
like Adventure like you could go into
any genre of anything and we're all
buying into it you've managed to do that
over the course of your career which is
huge huge and has to be earned oh thank
you thank you
thank you okay
yeah I do I have a farm yeah any recent
additions like any new animals oh my
gosh so many so many new additions well
uh we we have a lot of different
um
sheep and and goats that just uh had
babies recently so our Goat kids are
about a week and a half old right now
we've probably got about 30 of them go
kids have a really cute name don't they
kids kids yeah that's it yeah kids
what do they call a goat kid uh yeah
kids yeah they're calling kids which is
really cute because they are little kids
it's funny you know sheep and goats
they're really different right like a
sheep it just follows a Shepherd right
uh goats on the other hand are are
really finicky and they're stubborn you
know they want it to do it their way
they don't trust the shepherd they they
think they're going to figure it out so
a goat say for example you had like an
old car stereo sitting out in your field
which we had somehow a car stereo had
fallen out under the grass and as one
does as one somehow a car stereo ends up
in a field
um and the Sheep would stay away from it
but the goat would be like listen
I need to figure out what this thing is
I'm gonna eat it
and I think I love the metaphor for us
relying on our own understanding in a
way it's like you know what I got this
I'm gonna eat the car stereo I'll get
back to you and let you know what it is
you know okay well when your wife was
here and I bonded with her on her book
about forgiveness which I think is just
such a powerful thing yeah the gift of
forgiveness she wrote this book and it
she Chronicles several different stories
and their own Journeys with forgiveness
there's nothing about it that says you
need to do it one way or you need to do
another she was just really looking at
people in their forgiveness Journeys and
it's a fabulous book and so she's and
it's true she explores so many
variations of forms of forgiveness and
when I screw up I say hey
remember your book
remember
forgiveness is a gift honey
so you should probably forgive me
right well I asked her uh dating advice
and then she said oh well actually you
should speak to my mom yeah
um
do you think I should try to ask her to
matchmaking yeah she loves it really
yeah yeah yes yeah
I think that would be great she loves it
um she and Catherine both think
obsessively about this stuff so if you
if you be careful you set them out there
and they are going to uh they're going
to hurry it up they're going to get you
along you know well I mean I've been
single for seven years maybe are you
ready I don't for something fun and and
lovely you know right I that should be
pretty easy but it's not it's hard to
yes I guess it's it's a little bit It's
Tricky out there you know It's Tricky
you know what I really want is just to
get along and and be happy you know I
don't want any drama I just want to just
enjoy life well that's good that's good
I think if you want that I think you I
think you should be able to find that
it's a lot of knowing that you want
that's important don't don't go for a
difficult person I'm sorry
oh
dear I love you you're the best so
that's it
thank you for like confirming my best
hopes yeah you you bet I'll tell you man
I I've met Catherine uh now it's been
five maybe six years ago and
God has a fast forward button you know
like when it's right boom you hit you
and fall in love you get married you now
we have two we have two beautiful
daughters to add to you know my my
family and it's just it feels it feels
really great and then I was there was a
moment in my life that I was really
struggling and felt really broken and
and uh yeah it was like coming to
for me my own Journey like you know
finding a higher power and and um
leaning on that and feeling like being
like please save me and then feeling
saved
and then shortly later meeting you know
the woman of my dreams and being like
this is wow this feels great it's all
about timing and you know it's all it's
all there's a perfect plan out there for
you and I think uh he's gonna have to
have faith and and if you have the
minute you have faith
it falls into place
and you guys met through in a place of
Faith yeah we did yeah yeah we did we
met at a church she was in the yeah we
were I was like in the front row of
church which is like you kind of don't
want to be like whoa who's that at
church you know
but I was like kind of sneaking some
glances and I'm like who is that I
wonder who that is anyway what am I
doing come on I'm I'm broken help me
well who's that and uh yeah so we we
kind of hit it off and we didn't you
know we we didn't uh uh start dating
right away but we met there and then
like you know later on uh ended up going
out
and was it like a quick connection very
quick as you said God puts it on Fast
Forward yeah it was just there it was
like okay this all it all it all very it
made sense you know it's like when
you're you know you're doing a puzzle
yes and then you there's a piece and
you're like I'm certain that's the piece
and you like kind of jam it and it's
like it looks like it should be the P
isn't right and then you're like no I
mean is it oh it's that one like it just
fits together you're like oh that's okay
it fits because it's the piece that was
made to fit there that felt like that
did you always have access to this kind
of depth or did you have to earn not
until the moment I sat right down in
this chair
I think you have this magic ability to
pull inside of people out I was gonna be
like okay so Mario the Mario movie comes
out we're gonna talk about that and now
I'm like well yeah become a guru out
here
I came back
[Music]